[Music]
all right hello my name is Julian for
lako I am a national master from the
state of Missouri and today I'm going to
go over the Budapest gambit which is a
defense against d4 so the starting moves
are d4 Knight f6 c4 and this movie 75
which is the starting position of the
Budapest gambit now in order to refute a
gambit you must accept it so the best
move for white here is definitely D
takes e5 a move that cannot be
recommended is d4 d5 because Bishop c5
will just be good for black honestly
black has two pieces out and white has
zero and he's about to castle all of
black's pieces are very harmonious and
why does nothing to really show for it
so the only correct move here can be d
takes e5 and here the best move is
Knight g4 now first we should talk about
94 very briefly because it's not a very
good move here the best reply is
actually Knight to f3 Bishop b4 92 and
after 96 putting some pressure on e5 a
392 Bishop d2 if you retreat the bishop
then I to c5 I can expand with b4 so
probably you should take on d2 and
attack he 5 Queen c3 and white is just
better he has an extra pawn and
development is very easy after either
III or g3 white is definitely for choice
a more serious attempt for equality is
after D takes e5 to play the move Knight
g4 now I'll start with every line from
least popular to most popular so the
least popular line here is to play
Knight f3
now the
or I mean sorry the least popular line
is to play e4 but Knight f3 in this
position isn't as good as it was against
94 I will ask the audience why they
think that might be does anybody have
any idea why Knight of three in this
specific position could be potentially
worse than the than the line where the
knight was on e4 in this position what
white would really like to do because
blacks idea is he wants to play Knight
to c6 move his bishop out to either c5
or before and play Queen e7 and regain
his pawn on b4 only 5 while completing
development now from White's point of
view he'd like to play Knight f3 and
Bishop f4 and potentially just keep his
pawn on e5 right so after the move
Knight f3 what can black do to force a
concession from white Bishop b4 is
actually incorrect right now because
after Bishop before why it would just
respond with Bishop d2 I don't know you
can continue the only a few do you like
would you know one from okay I'm
developing to move with tempo and like
if you take and I take with my Queen
potentially my Quentin can go to f4 and
just defend my pawn on e5 attack your
knight on g4 this position is very good
for a white but you are right you do
want to move your Bishop out and here
you can move it to c5 attacking f2 and
now White's forced to play e3 and the
bishop cannot go to f4 so since since
the bishop cannot go to f4 black can
just play knight c6 and we will return
to this line in a second what should be
mentioned is white can immediately give
back his pawn which is not at all
critical but I mean you have to consider
with the movie for Knight takes Knight
takes e4
that's right Knight takes e5 f4 so White
has a lot of control of the center with
this pawn on c4 control II d5 and a nice
do on e4 and f4 but after Knight to c6
Knight ec6
white is forced to play Bishop e3
because if you play Knight f3 what would
you play here with black
what where would you like to put this
bishop ideally on this most useful
diagonal the Seif us all right the a7 to
g1 to agonal right so here black can
just play Bishop c5 and he's already
totally fine it might be even some
slight preference to black so why does
probably forced to play Bishop III and
then Bishop before check now Bishop d2
doesn't make any sense right because I
played Bishop III back to d2 so Knight
c3 could be bad because of Bishop c3
doubling the pawns to and you can
contain a continue normally here by
bringing your knight to c5 and black is
already fine so II four isn't very
critical so the main moves we have to
look at our Knight of three and Bishop
a4 so let's go back to Knight f3 for the
time being
and the reason why this line is actually
considered not to be very good for white
anymore
even though some some very strong
players have played it is because after
black goes knight Knight to c6 white
plays Bishop e2 castles castles taking
on e5 also transposes well I can take on
e5 any time you once now later it
doesn't matter rook e8 black just making
more preparatory moves Knight c3 and I
and IG takes Knight C takes I believe
also transposes so takes takes takes b3
now in this position white used to think
well black doesn't really have like any
useful moves because after d6 it's very
clear that white is better like all of
my pieces are better than yours I have a
with my Bishop being on this diagonal my
knight could potentially come to d5 or
efore it's not clear where your pieces
want to be but then they discover it a
really a really nice maneuver and would
you guys like to attempt to find the
move that changed basically the entire
evaluation of this position
so black has a very nice idea these
pieces basically you need to think what
do these pieces want to do in the long
term where do they want to live if you
play d6 right now then everything that I
just mentioned is true right
white white will have better pieces than
you he has slightly more space and you
will be slightly worse so you need to
think where does my rook want to be
that's your big hint okay so where would
you rather where would you rather have
your work on d8 orgy sex or h6 this work
here
yeah you'd want it you'd want it over on
the kingside right because it can attack
so the best move here is a 5 there
should be 2 Broke a 6 and this position
is very unclear and honestly I'd rather
be black here most most games in the
database and in blacks favor and the
computer thinks this is very slightly
better for white which it would because
space it's programmed to like space so
rook a 6 and this position is unclear
and honestly if black is this in any
game then he could consider the opening
to be a success so that is that is one
line now the most common move here is
Bishop f4 because if you've seen this
position before you know after Knight f3
Bishop c5 you're forced to play e3 and
you want to have your Bishop on f4 to
then play Knight f3
so now Bishop c5 doesn't make any sense
because III would attack the knight and
I've defended up to my bishops already
on it for defending the five point white
is just clearly better here so fish
about for the best move is knight c6
attacking you 5 Knight f3
and now after Bishop c5 in the sir
what's happening okay Knight of three
Bishop c5 here white can probably just
play e3 continue with development and I
mean he he might not be losing this pawn
immediately I can kick the night away
with h6 eventually probably Queenie 725
it's fine for fine for white just like
this this position
go back I've gained a tempo my Knights
coming to d5 basically white is just
better you can't just move your Bishop
to c5 now that the bishops on it for the
best move here is Bishop before check
and there are two lines one line is
knight Knight c3 and the other line is
92 I will go over the thing that
everybody who has ever reviewed the the
Budapest talks about which is Knight 92
Queen e2 7 and now a3 which is a slight
inaccuracy now the point is white wants
to get the bishop pair so if black just
plays Bishop d2 Queen d2 you will have a
slight advantage maybe but it's black to
move what would you play in this
position
right and what's the what's the point so
if I take on before so if you don't have
anything you're down a piece right
problem is do you have something a queen
before I mean again I'm I can even be up
two pieces ready to take on e5 so yeah
you have a thing here that immediately
forces your opponent to sign your score
sheet so
I know you know at home you have like
all your engines like telling you the
answer God all right
93 and check me yeah I can't take
because the computer won't let me and
the keenest rap so that's me and
everybody likes to talk about this
they're like oh my god I can't wrap my
opponent and you know he's gonna take my
bishop and I'll win in like five moves
but okay it wait so the tactics work out
here for black because after 95 95
Bishop e5 Intermezzo right so if black
just takes on e5 then he loses his
bishop on before but what would you play
here with black in order not to lose
material to check right and black
interpolates a intermediate move Queen
d2 King D to is not to be recommended
Queen Queen e5 and yeah with such with
material being reduced the whites very
slight space advantage shouldn't matter
and black has basically reached full
equality so this type of position is
nothing for white after a 395 95 is the
best move 95 and the the best move for
white is III just continue but let us go
back to this position black has a
sideline so in this position they used
to think it was forced to just play 96
and attack the pawn but here like has a
very interesting move in g5 so if my
bishop just moves away somewhere like c1
then I'm gonna play Knight takes e5
that's the point
so Bishop g3 side line is Bishop d2 95
Knight of 3 should be 795 take or ship
c3 96 but this position is I mean it's
very interesting the white could argue
the pawn on g5 is slightly weak the f5
square could be weak but on the other
hand black is ahead and development so
that's one of the Trump's
he has and he's not forced to Castle
King side he could also cancel a queen
side and this position is very
interesting material equality that's
been established both sides have Trump's
probably at the positions around equal
more interesting is Bishop to g3 Bishop
g7 Knight f3 knight c6 Knight c3 95
white can't really hold on to his pawn
here if you play something like Queen d5
then eventually a night before could be
a potential issue I don't even have to
do it now I can just castle I could do
it now
and you're probably not gonna be a
little hold on to your pawn anyway
because rikiei will comment E 5 will be
too weak so white can't hold on to his
pawn so he may as well just get give it
up now 95 95 95 and the best move here
is H for e3 here probably the best thing
if you know what what'll happen the the
best thing for black to do is to play h5
here with a point that after h4 you go
g4 but after d6h for g4 white is clearly
better after h5 here black should play
h6 but every game in the database
continues Bishop e6 I don't know why h6
Bishop f6 95 and white is substantially
better because he's going to claim the
bishop pair potentially a knight on I
don't know four could be strong g4 is
weak f4 and a 5 are both
chronically weak so yeah I mean black
doesn't really have anything in exchange
exchange for this whites position is
very solid and I mean black has a lot of
weaknesses now the best thing I can do
here is to play h6 Bishop h4 some
annoyance Bishop f6 is a very bad move
because I take and play 95 Queen d7 95
and f5 and this position is better for
white probably significantly better for
white but it's very unbalanced and both
sides can play for 1 which is the
benefit to playing this with black so
that's that's the best way for white to
play well rather the best way for white
to place to play h4 here and then
transpose to that by playing h5 if you
play e3 here then black can play h5 and
avoid that after h4 g4 h 5y can black
not take on c4
anybody know
there might be more than one shoe III
you could play III III is like the right
idea but II four is actually better
because you have slightly more space and
here it's funny night be to Queen c2
night a for I believe this is how the
line goes ninety five and if you take
this dude then your queen is I'm sorry
this is immediately winning also I think
in this position ninety five wins
because c7 is so weak but yeah II for
efore is best I think Knight B to 1 C 2
and 8 for I believe 95 here bishop a1
and yeah Bishop Bishop c7 Queen g5
Bishop f4 and then I put my knight on c7
so black has a lot of weaknesses the
site isn't developed ok my bishop isn't
develop at least my work is doing
something so this position is just bad
for black in fact that's just lost so
yeah that that's that line g5 is an
interesting sideline but honestly it
shouldn't in any classical game with
where White's well prepared
white should have a significant
advantage out of the opening so the best
move is 9 c6 Knight f3 Bishop b4 and
here there are two main lines one being
92 and the other being 93 now 92 is the
safe mainline 93 is the strategically
dangerous mainline because after this
black and played Bishop c3 be c3 and you
have weaknesses on the C file after 92
which has no strategic risk white is
just trying to play for the two bishops
a3 is what we discussed let's continue
down this line 95 95 95 and III so the
point of a3 is I want the bishop pair so
Bishop d2 Queen d2 and here there
to Maine moose one bean castles and the
other being d6
it my personal preference is d6 because
I don't think it's so clear that the
best place for blacks came to be is on
g8 potentially c8 is better and
potentially FAS better so d6 is kind of
like hedging my bets d6 queenie Bishop
e2 castles here sorry sorry let's start
with castles castles here this should be
- I let's do it through this move order
here
castles black can play Bishop g600
castles 96 Bishop d3 and Bishop f5 this
position is very solid for black but
honestly I would I would never play this
type of position with luck because why
does the two bishops he has more space
it's very easy for for white to proceed
White has all of the trumps and it's
hard to say what black really has to
show for this in my opinion the best
line here is d6 there should be two and
then instead of instead of castles b6 is
better because in our castles but should
be 7b 496 Bishop g3 and here black can
play h5 so I'm trying to harass the
bishop and with the rook being on the H
file potentially if I open the H file I
could have a very dangerous battery so
yeah
this position is very unclear and if
like it's it then he has had a very
successful opening because he's he's not
lost and it's very very playable and
interesting now after a 3 because a
three forces black to play Bishop d2
Bishop c5 is no good people people with
white we're thinking huh if I don't play
a three maybe my opponent will be forced
to play Bishop d2 anyway so I could like
gain of like a more useful because a3
isn't that useful to White's position it
reinforces before but honestly having
Bishop e2 and castles one tempo faster
is more useful than having the be four
squares slightly more protective so III
is a better move here 95 95 95 Bishop e2
and honestly the main move here okay
I actually prefer castles in this
specific position over over the one with
a three so after a three I think Bishop
d2 and d6 is better then then castles
but in this position I think castles is
better because after castles castles
Black has this additional option of
playing Knight g6 Black's of Putin play
and went after Bishop c7
anybody got any ideas that is correct
d6 and the bishop has no squares and
it's attacked so why just loses a piece
so the the policy 7 is taboo bishop g3
and here I can play Bishop d6 which
looks a little awkward because you're
coming in the bishop on C a well in the
other hand you're immediately going to
get rid of the the bishop you're going
to trade these bishops and then you're
gonna play d6 so you don't give white
the the bishop pair so Bishop d6 is the
best move Queen d6 94 Queen d7 93 d7 d8
and this position is slightly better for
white but at least he doesn't have the
bishop pair and blacks position is very
solid so that that would be like my
recommendation if you were playing this
with if you hope to play this with the
black pieces I would play this line here
96 and Bishop d6 now the main goal here
is actually Bishop d2 so if you play
this with the white pieces most people
are going to just take this guy and it's
kind of like you've gained a tempo
because you haven't played a through you
all right now the third line we have to
discuss or sorry I'm getting ahead of
myself so a a line we have to discuss
here is
in the safe remain lines is the I guess
we could nickname it the carp offline
which is castles castles and assuming
black plays d6 here instead of Knight g6
and Bishop d6 now white can play Knight
B 3 and I've trapped the bishop I mean
not like I'm gonna win the bishop for
nothing but I'm gonna gain the bishop
pair the next move by playing a3 so b6
a3 Bishop c5 Knight c5 and can anybody
tell me why d c5 is not playable
free night how that sorry what
even you're actually right it is a free
night yes Queen d5 attacking the rook on
a a and the knight on e5 so free night
all right
so DC fire is not playable which means
BC is forced B 497 if black just plays
takes and takes the a pawn is isolated
White has two bishops he's gonna fix the
structure with b5 and he's just clearly
better
so 97 hoping for BC and 95 we're
actually why would have the weaknesses
on c4 and a 3 but here Bishop g4 and
this is our tabia short has played this
twice once again scarp off and once
again C von Schuch
against Karpov he played a5 and he lost
that game against the Yvonne Chaka later
he played rook e8 and drew and like 10
moves well look it we'll look at that in
a second so this is also one of the
lines that that why can why can go for
and the last line that I can go for
before we look at some games is the the
strategically dangerous main lines with
Knight c3
so sorry training so here Queenie 725 so
white trice did it to hang on to us to
his material advantage f6 so black
already gave up on the idea of just
winning his his pawn back and instead
place for compensation
so after EF and Bishop c3 BC and Knight
f6 it's important to throw this move in
first because if you play Knight f6 I
could potentially just play Queen D 3
and now Bishop c3 doesn't double my
pawns
so Bishop c3 first and then Knight f6
now after Queen D 1 or 23 sorry yeah
Queen D 1 Queen d3 is a better move
it's weird here white is up upon but in
exchange for a pawn black has the F file
to work with white spawns why does two
very weak pawns on the C file and a lot
of counter play involving the fact that
white isn't fully developed yet so this
this position is also very interesting
so let's move on to some games and you
you tell me at some point if you think
the opening has been success for white
or black so this is a game between
Mammadov verse mom and dr f d4 906 so we
get to our starting position Knight f3
Bishop c5 so this line is considered
what for for white it's good bad unclear
equal
yeah because this is a slight a slight
concession right because you're forcing
the pawn to e3 now the bishop cannot
guard the pawn on e5 throughout four so
knight c6 93 95 95 should be too we get
to our the position and black what
should black play here there's it's a
very important because if you don't do
it and do this then white is just
clearly better for black yeah you're our
only hope
what rook a six yes that is correct yeah
okay six all right and now 94 so Bishop
a7 can somebody tell me other than
Claudio why the bishop moved to a seven
instead of f8
yes that is correct so basically you
want the bishop on a seven to be aimed
at the e3 and have to pawn structure
even though the like normally this would
overrule a bishop on this diagonal here
there are some sacrifices that could
potentially be devastating so the bishop
on a seven is its most active position a
seven is its most active position so
here at 93 rook h6 so so the point of
work a6 was to swing the rook over and
now that the rook is on h6 we can
complete our development with d6
so it's kind of like we cheated right we
after d6 we played rook here and our
cure which isn't a lot but if you do it
first then it is so Knight f5 was played
rook f6 and here F for rook f5 takes and
in the game black played rook takes e5
which is very tempting and this position
is very slightly better for black but
honestly black was just winning here
with rook takes f1 like rook takes f1
and then you take on e3 in your upper
part nothing wrong with this the opening
is a huge success for black between two
very strong grandmasters one being rated
2660 and the other I think at the time
being only rated 2700 but right now
Mahmoud you are frustrated 2800 and like
number 5 in the world so these these
guys are no jokes and I mean black got a
very playable position in the supposedly
bad opening keen-edged one was played
which is another mistake now black
should just move his rook back and he's
up a pawn in e3 is a weak white should
really take should really take the rook
and then it's funny but material is
equal because I have two pawns and a
bishop for the exchange so this position
is equal after Bishop g4 it's you should
play Bishop g4 like if you play some
random move like eight let's say Rock B
1 then D then D 6 and black is much
better because two bishops and usually a
bishop and two pawns is better than a
look I'm very slightly so this position
would be slightly better for black but
after this Bishop g4 unless you want to
play b6 and Bishop e7 which is bad
because d7 signing then you're going to
probably have to give up the bishop pair
with I mean material equality and a
roughly equal position instead white
played cane h1 and then here instead of
playing Ricky six black player x g5
which is an inaccuracy Bishop h5 which
wins a different kind of exchange f6 I'm
attacking f7 right and it's hard to
defend f7 rook g6 is no good work a
tribe is no good the best way to to give
up the exchanges f6 takes takes here but
shifty for black puts his bishop back on
ba because he wants to retain the bishop
pair Queen f3 which is just I mean okay
to be fair like this is engine analysis
and a very strong player played Queen f3
so it's not like the worst move in the
position but it's it it misses blacks
idea which is c5 Bishop c3 and d5 and
Black has a very active position he's
kind of attacking the Kings side the
opening obviously like long long ago was
this was a success and getting such a
position with the black pieces is
unprecedented
so yeah the game continued the game is
not so interesting to the topic of
discussion yeah so after after rook g3
queen up to Bishop h3 just wins it's a
nice sacrifice on if you take you get
made it my queen coming to g6 or my row
coming to h2 so like here if King G to
then work h2 one's your queen
like that go here then I go here which
is me I mean I'm going to make some time
soon
so I mean you don't even need to
calculate it it's just the one material
so we will move on to the next game
this was a success for black this was a
game between Pavel Ileana and Shakira
mama D are the same player who plays who
played last game actually mom and ER f I
believe is the strongest player in the
world who has consistently played the
Putin at the Budapest gambit well let's
see how this turned out d4 c4 c5 the
Buddha the Budapest takes Knight g4
Bishop f4 the best and here g5 which is
a little dubious but if I mean Pavel
Ileana if is very strong player I
believe either the best or the second
best player in Ukraine number 15 - like
10 he's number 1 yeah yes h3 here or
wait
right Oh h3 here I believe alright so I
I think I know why this is bad I'm gonna
ask the class
why do you what move would you play here
with black so Mario has pointed out that
this is an N or mezzo so if you take
which by the way I'm not even convinced
this positions like that good for you
but I know that there's a better move
here so black has an intermezzo here
after a white syndrome is better all
right
I believe Knight takes f2 is very strong
because after you take I take yeah and
after you take here like this I take you
take Bishop c5 is probably ending the
game like now Queen g3 it might be
strong but I think this is very strong
should be three how do you stop me from
coming here I don't know so yeah i think
i think after h3 night off to a strong I
don't know yeah
so that's why you have to move your
bishop so by the way if you're playing
with the black pieces you might be able
to trap somebody like that could play
and then Knight up - it's good for blitz
Bishop g3 I'm sorry Bishop d2 is played
in this game which by the way this is
already like a minor victory for for
black because if your opponent doesn't
played like the best moves here he might
not be better and also I mean the reason
why you'd play the Budapest is like you
need this might be like a must-win okay
to be fair this was Moscow like tall
memorial blitz but these guys are strong
so you can still like learn a lot from
their games they're incredibly strong
and fast time controls so 95 bishops e39
c6 e 3 d6 and Bishop g7 yeah I would
already say the opening is this has got
a success for black just because once
again he played g5 he's not like totally
busted on the opening he got something
very playable very interesting
and white doesn't really I mean the
weaknesses aren't so important compared
to blacks development advantage so 95 by
the way um the Knights on e5 and c6 are
super Phyllis Knights in other words
they want to occupy the same squares
when white takes one of them off like
that's also like a minor victory because
now I have one night which serves one
purpose which is good now my my knight
makes a lot of sense on on e5 so yeah
but should be too
yeah f4 isn't playable because it takes
takes and I just Castle yeah if you take
this guy usually in these types of
positions where some guy plays f3 takes
e4 like in the King's gambit where they
play f4 it takes e5 there's this tactic
where they go Queen h4 and if g3 then
Queenie four wins the rook so yeah
anyway Bishop b2 castles castles Queenie
792 b63 Bishop e7 this position is are
like Rd blacks for choice objectively
speaking practically speaking every
everything is going his way
rook da Rick d1 c5 normally the way
you'd punish this type of pawn structure
is to play like efore but efore is not
playable
therefore this position is not good for
where it takes takes f5 now there's
nothing wrong with blacks position in
fact this is an improvement over like
Kings Indians or nimzo-indian like
basically when I get this type of
position with both of my bishops working
in conjunction with each other
black is just for choice as I've already
said so yeah the rest of the game isn't
that important basically white didn't
play so accurately in the opening so he
ended up with the worst position and
black won a very nice game all right
let's move on to the next example of
this Lane game between Retta saw boychik
who is the best player in poland a
second of a non
I mean lots and lots of accomplishments
throughout his chest career and his
opponent is buddy or Joe bhava who is
sorry
bad year Joe Baba he is the best player
in Georgia
I believe I I mean it's hard to be
better than 2700 so I don't I don't know
a lot of guys I think he's the best
player in Georgia he got a gold medal in
the Olympiad with like a 2950
performance rating so he's he's
obviously well known he also has played
the budapest gambit from time to time
although he's not stronger than moment
yards it probably is the second best
player who plays it consistently well I
mean these guys play like everything
they're kind of wild and crazy but
they're the only guys who really play it
let's say anyway d4 Knight f6 e4 e5
takes on e5 Knight g4 Bishop f4 g5
Bishop g3 1996 knight of three the best
move yeah so tonight of 35 Bishop g7 and
H forest is correct Knight takes Knight
takes and here probably just night in 93
yeah
so after g4 III was played the best
movies h5 as mentioned before
transposing to the main line and white
is better because d6 h6 and 95 and I'm
going to claim something
yeah taking on c4 is not playable
because of this this by the way traps
the Queen Queen has no squares anyway
your gg4 would be played so yeah h4 g4
III and here the best move is h5
probably just stopping H five in the
game d6 was played then Bishop e2 once
again the best move is h5 in every
position where I can play h5 he should
so Bishop b2 should be six rook c1 which
is an accurate by the way black is
already totally fine so this is like a
huge opening success you've you have a
very nice pieces your Bishop is an
active on this diagonal your 9 didn't
your Bishop are aimed at c4 and castling
after you Castle queenside and I mean
you f like weaknesses on f5 and f4 which
is why you're not just like winning with
black but since your pieces are your
pieces are active enough to compensate
for your structural weaknesses anyway
castles castles King side was played
probably better was to do what I said
Queen e7 to counsel the Queen side but
castles King side was played in this
game
c6 stopping Andy 95 nonsense h5 finally
F v h6 Bishop f6 black is arranging all
of his pieces in such a way to achieve
f4 eventually because if I achieve f4
with all of my pieces in the center
while your Kings still on castled
opening up the positioned and probably
I'll just be winning if you Castle then
potentially your age 6 h6 pawn will look
really silly well I might just take it
without a rook being on each one so
that's why white had to react now with
f4 and okay black-ish it's just better
now take takes King h8 for rook d8 is a
nice move yeah the point is that now I'm
now I'm getting f4 and couldn't before
stuff I'm very active and your Kings in
the center so yeah
yeah yeah this is very yeah tall esque
yeah yeah I mean obviously the opening
was already a successful black pit yeah
the rest of this game isn't so important
but I mean black one and like very fast
yeah after 94 white just resigned
because we're G 3 ends again so anyway
let's move on to our next example
another game between well another game
where mama drf is as saying the blast of
the black pieces see sorry what I mean I
should yeah but I don't know people on
the interwebs in her blogs blogosphere
can find their own pictures of Mahmud
Yara to look at during the video yeah
yeah anyway um he he obviously plays a
lot of games with black so anyway so we
reach we reach one of our main positions
and this after Bishop g7 the best move
is Knight c3 once again Knight c3 95 h4
h5 etc but yeah we get something similar
in this game 90 this is really an
accurate you shouldn't play this way the
whole idea I mean the night looks really
nice on f4 but it's kind of like fake
because after after 95 like I've traded
off a pair of Knights which helps black
as I said before the Knights on c6 and
e5 like step on each other's toes the
knight on f4 the only purpose is to
attack h5 so I mean it's it looks nice
but it's like a paper tiger it's not
doing all
what okay so Bishop e6
I mean if white wants to take now he
could but I assume this is just fine my
structures final castle and I have the F
file yeah so castles black has already
achieved a lot in the opening this is a
huge success black again won a nice game
96 is a nice pawn sacrifice because all
of my pieces are nice and it's not clear
where your king wants to live it's not
going over there look at what you've
done right and over here
I mean I'm stronger on the side and h4
is hanging so I mean yeah
White's keen is stuck in the center and
okay rook g4 is once again I mean
there's problems on f2 so there's
potentially three tactics I mean h h4 is
hanging whatever the opening is
successful for black now we will
hopefully end all delusions of g5 okay
so here we're just training right
this is an example of what white should
do why should you play Knight c3 take on
e5 okay II threw slide and accuracy but
now H for now h5 h6 Knight d5 so white
has played every correct move and has a
very tangible open an advantage it takes
takes and by the way whenever this
happens whenever some trade occurs on d5
with a pawn being on c7 on being on d6
c7 becomes a point of Congress because
when I put my pieces on the C file
you're always going to have to consider
the consequences of c6 so why could
potentially just went up on on this on
c7 so like imagine I played Bishop b2
and Castle kingside
I put all my pieces on the C file the C
pawn could just fall off the board so
this this trade helps white
there should be two why does the two
bishops the only bad part about his
position is age six potentially but age
six was played to force all of this
nonsense
so yeah rook g8 rook c1 Queen c2 Queen
b3 I mean this is slightly inaccurate so
but this should be five there should be
five there should be five this position
is just good for white white notices
that if he castles then black has a real
counter play on the Kings side this is
actually better to keep asking in the
center here and okay g3 is played to
stop any counter play with f4 and now he
brings his rook to attack the weakness
on C South created by this trade on d5
so Rick f7 or k4 and I mean the open was
a huge success for white white is just
winning yeah and a hue this was very
easy to win
yeah I like how the computer said rook
c7 enact inaccuracy taking the position
from plus 5s and my two plus six but
whatever I mean philosoph I was gonna
yeah yeah whatever
yeah dubious the computers complaining
that the position that was already lost
whence and more lost doesn't make any
sense
alright yeah
all right anyway a game between
Kovalenko and Cavalli off d4 and we get
our starting position and g v g5 bishop
g3 for ship g7 night of 396 so once
again h4 is the thing to do this is an
interesting line for white this is an
alternative if you don't like being like
much better and closer to winning with
h5 and 9c3
i mean i don't know why you wouldn't
want to have that but let's say you
don't write you 92 is very possible a g4
III and you have this interesting idea
of playing Queen c2 c5 d5 the point of
c5 is if black doesn't do anything you
could have there could be a weakness on
d6 because Queen takes there could be
some tactics with Knight c4 in this pen
and also now that the pawn races d5
there's a very nice score on d4 for my
knight yeah
h5 Bishop f6 castles Queen side queenie
793 c6 94 and i mean this is a very
interesting position white is much
better
so yeah white won a very nice game if
you want to look up this game as
Kovalenko vers kavali off european
bullets 2000 2014 alright now we will
reach the main lines which we will start
with a very funny game which hopefully
nobody will ever repeat but it okay it's
starting position and here instead of g5
which is a bad move knight c6 which
offers some I mean surprisingly decent
chances to equalize Knight of three
Bishop before 92 Queen e7 like this is
basically where you would start your
analysis with both sides because the
other lines are kind of inferior so you
don't really need to look at them that
much so you would start here and then
you would with with either black or
white you would say okay this is what I
do this is my opponent does so if you
want to look at this like with a
computer
you you should start with this physician
with either color if you want to play
with white you start here if you want to
play with black mr. black needs to look
at more stuff but if you want to play
this line with white you can a3 is an
inaccuracy why could somebody tell me
Knight takes Knight takes e5 is correct
pointed out earlier but I mean Claudia
seasons in two seconds I can't take on
before because yeah 93 is me so 95 95
III the reason why you three is an
inaccuracy is a kind of ways to tempo
I'm putting the question to the bishop
but the bishop might want to take the
night anyway
but okay this is the line that was put
in this game so we continue Queen d2 d6
is the best move order here but should
be too and in this game castles what was
played the best move I believe is b6 but
we'll look at that in a second castles
be for a five castles b6 so oftentimes
you'll find that the bishops best
diagonal is on is here the long diagonal
yester likes to say the bishops like a
magnet on the long diagonal makes me
really happy when he says it but yeah
it's it's true so anyway why tries to
break up the structure with c5 now in
this position you can take on on c5 with
the D pawn queen d5 is the same tactic
which was played the best move is just
to take but okay in the game Queen d5
was played Bishop g4 f3 there the Bishop
g4 is the only move not to lose material
so you can't take on e5 because well if
you take with the Queen I take with the
Queen and take on you too
so I haven't lost any material right
it's very solid black if you take on the
e5 with your Bishop I take on E - so f3
so I'm attacking both your Bishop and
your knight now you do lose a piece but
you lose a piece in a very interesting
way ninety-six takes takes takes and now
you take on e3 and after rook F 2 which
is forced if you move your king here I
take your rook or here I take your
bishop
the two I have choices you have to you
have to move your work back and block
now I have eight takes and due to this
pin you cannot take back so I have a lot
of pawns for the piece now this game is
really funny because after Queen f3
Queen e5 was played and white played
Bishop c4 and both players are rated so
this is a blitz game to be fair but one
player is rated 2670 the others rated
2604 and the way the game ended was
Queen takes a it won't was played and
then well I mean what can I do
he's down every pollen on the board and
it's an exchange so yeah but if this is
a very interesting position to start
with like this one is I mean I would
why should never go for this because
it's like equal and interesting which is
good for black but I mean if you want if
you want to explore this position you
can the next game is I believe a
slightly better move order which black
employees after after Bishop e2 here
instead of castling should play b6
castles Bishop d7 beef before the point
is 96 and now you have h5 because your
works on h8 so c5 takes takes h4 black
is already like 4 choice so this was a
huge opening successful if you manage to
play 96 and h5 I think this positions
around equal I mean why does the bishop
pair but at the same time his King side
is so weak like c6 was played and now
blacks already better opening is a huge
success and like white just lost really
quickly
he lost the bishop pair immediately
because the bishops trapped right so he
has to move back to f4 904 take rook c5
Bishop e6 I mean the the pawn is a
weakness on c6 not a strength you have
the worst Bishop I mean black is just
better so I mean the opening is not
important once again black had the
successful opening we can move on if you
want to look up this game this is a
Erin Leigh Leigh me or whatever is some
French dude against winkles Robin yeah
all right now we get to the main line of
the main lines which is which is anatoly
karpov against Nigel short everybody in
this room should know who Karpov is and
hopefully everybody in this room knows
who short is I mean both I mean
obviously car pop wasn't world champion
one of the strongest players in chess
history and short played a match with
car sorry Kasparov also with Karpov but
with Kasparov for the World Championship
so very strong players short actually
played the Budapest in the candidates no
less so this is very serious tournament
this isn't like a blitz game like he
actually wanted to play this opening in
96 it should be 492 Karpov wasn't one
for taking a lot of like strategic risk
so 93 didn't really appeal to him so 92
Queenie 7 and Karpov doesn't play a 3
because he's good at chess 95 95 Bishop
e2 castles castles and here my
recommended sideline for any budapest
players out there is 96 Bishop g3 I once
again I'll mention this and Bishop d6
with again the point that you aren't
losing the bishop pair but this position
is also solid if you if you want to play
this d6 Knight b3 b6 a3 push-ups e5 take
take be 497 Bishop g4 and this position
I believe is slightly better for white
although black is very decent holding
chances this this is successful for
white because I mean he's gained an
opening advantage he has something very
real to play with I mean this structure
isn't very good for black why does the
bishop pair I mean he's gonna give it
away but for for these pawns so these
these are weak the computer will say
this is like very very like 0.3 or
something like something normal
white has a very normal opening and
advantage but I think long-term black is
suffering and actually a short chose to
improve against Yvonne shook here by
playing Ricky eight we can take a look
at how Karpov proceeded he played Queen
d5 putting some pressure on c5 but
mostly trying to play Queen e5 and trade
the Queen's so Queenie fire rookie six
and he took on c7 so that's one point
and then Queen b7 he puts his work on
the open file he plays f3 just because I
mean potentially he could play bishop
I said I eat for Bishop back to e3 and
target the c5 pawn yeah h3 Queen c2 he
puts all of his pieces on like they're
best squares he tries to move his rook
to the to the B file potentially stop
eating nonsense on g2 now I'm just
moving this to the D file the opening is
a huge success for Wyatt because he's
basically just winning so we can move on
to the next game which is Yvonne shook
short which ended like immediately it
ended with after the opening so it's
good for black drawing takes takes takes
castles and then white us to play Knight
b3 to be better if he doesn't then he's
not I play a5 Bishop c5 so Knight b3 b6
a3 for should be c5 take take we get our
starting position Bishop g4 and here
sure didn't like what happened to him
against Karpov I mean who would so that
you played rook e8 rook C 105 now his
point is the rook is is worse on c1 than
a once and now it's appropriate to
strike with a5 Bishop d7 Bishop d7 take
take Queen d5 and now the same work a6
Queen d6 and they agreed to draw here
because white has this repetition with
Bishop f4 but should be v Queen d6
Bishop at 455 et cetera so this is a
success with black because you have the
black pieces if you make like an easy
draw like this than everybody in the
world
playing the Budapest I mean nobody in
the world is playing the Budapest so
probably why does improvements but we'll
say that was a success now we move on to
the last line which is probably the most
critical and that is the strategically
risky Knight c3 this is a game between
Aronian and Evon shook Aronian number
two player in the world consistently for
like ever until recently and then he
finally came back to number 2 in the
world player who's always like near 2800
if not over and Evon shook i mean like i
want to say the second strongest player
in ukraine after Eliana at the moment
but he's a monster i keep like he lasted
the World Cup before ever his peak
rating was like 27 98 so very strong
player yeah they reach this position so
after Knight f6 Queen d3 was played
queen d1 and III is an inferior line but
it's like safer because you're not gonna
blunder your c4 pawn so that's the
appeal but Queen d3 g3 and Bishop g2
Bishop g4 castles and here white does
give up his bishop pair but he's up a
pawn and now Knight a5 is played White
has a definite advantage now he has no
weaknesses on C 4 and C 3 but he has
Bishop against Knight which is an
advantage kind of in and of itself
because bishops are very slightly better
than Knights and I mean the pawns are
doubled but it's a pawn so it's
something you can feel now this is
correct what Evon trick did 97 Queen e4
and c6 and black tried to play Knight b6
I believe 95 is a possible improvement
for any black players out there but yeah
I think
yeah 96 is a slight inaccuracy 95 very
slightly better but okay why it should
be slightly better in all of the main
lines and that there's no exception here
another possible line for white to play
I mean for white players is what
happened between Dean li Ren China's
number one player and Jo
sorry Xiao Jun who is like China's I
don't I don't know like fifth best fifth
he's he's top ten in China I think
something like that so we reach our
tabia queen d3 and g3 and here with
white instead of playing night of five
which Aronian played against Eve on
trick why just played nine c2 which may
be an improvement because after Eve for
Queen d2 Queen blockades on e3 the night
can potentially go to d4 and back here
it could potentially go here to here I
mean white has a point and is pressing
in all of these position positions f4 is
a nice move Hassan is impossible due to
the Queen painting on e7 yeah and then
white one the second pawn and want a
very nice ending once again the opening
wasn't that's right the the game itself
wasn't so important the thing to note
was white had a very successful opening
in the 93 line with 92 I would encourage
everybody to do additional study on the
games themselves thank you very much
that was my coverage of the Budapest
camp
[Music]